they say that age is just a number just
a number just a number just a number
[Music]
but i call [ __ ] on that
i think aging is a perspective
aging can harden you to long-held
beliefs that don't serve you
or it can bring you wisdom
aging can restrict your sense of
possibility
or it can unlock your further potential
aging can be used to excuse yourself
from new experiences and challenges or
it can be the catalyst for pursuing your
most meaningful goals
aging happens to everyone but
allowing it to limit you is a choice
so the question becomes
are you going to let aging defeat you
or
are you going to leverage it to empower
you
that preface was my way of welcoming you
to our fourth masterclass episode in
which we share big truths from some of
my best podcast guests honing in on a
single theme or subject matter and today
we're going to dive deep into the
subject of longevity we talk a lot about
longevity on this show from a science
and technology to diet and mindset
perspective but beyond the amazing
information you're about to hear the
real foundational truth i want to begin
with is this
longevity is possible because there are
choices that you can make to access not
simply the longest life span possible
but also the greatest health span your
body is capable of
there are real
tangible practical methods that we can
employ to get the maximum value out of
our bodies and therefore our lives
large populations of people around the
world are already achieving amazing
longevity results and we know this from
the work of my first guest dan buettner
dan buettner is a bit of a longevity
superhero he's a renaissance man he's
also a national geographic fellow and
multiple new york times best-selling
author but he is perhaps best known for
his work with the quote-unquote blue
zones which are these
communities spread around the world that
boast the highest per capita populations
of centenarians essentially places where
people not only live inordinately long
but also seem to resoundingly be living
happier than their fellow western world
counterparts so in this first clip dan's
going to offer a primer on how to live a
long and fulfilling life
based on his many years of studying
these blue zones populations around the
world and maybe not surprisingly
nutrition plays a key role so this is me
and dan buettner
for those people listening or watching
who
who are new to kind of your work um i
think it would be helpful to just kind
of provide a quick synopsis of what this
whole blues zones thing you know is
about
so we found longevity hot spots in
okinawa japan sardinia italy korea
greece nicoya peninsula of costa rica
and not far from here
uh that loma lean to california and the
seventh-day adventists
and over the past 15 years i've been
studying these cultures in a in an
effort to preserve
this
interconnected
set of factors that are common to all
these places that are yielding longevity
right so amongst these populations none
of them are are
striving for longevity they're not
thinking about it they're not going to
the gym they're not dieting their
lifestyles are set up in a certain way
that is conducive to them becoming
centenarian right the foods they eat the
manner in which they interact with their
community
uh and and interact
you know throughout their daily lives in
a physical sense all of these things
kind of contribute to
this um set of parameters that you have
kind of distilled down and and canonized
that's right so the i would say the big
epiphany and it took me 10 years to to
make this realization
you know in in america we tend to pursue
health we find a diet or we find an
exercise program or we we we get a coach
or we um
get on a supplement program
and we think well we got to find this
program we need the discipline the focus
of mind and and we're going to go after
it you know and
the vast majority
90 plus percent of people fail at what
they start at within a year
in blue zones
these people are
eating mostly plant-based foods they're
moving every 20 minutes or so they're
hugely socially connected they're
suffused with purpose
not because they've tried
it's because they're a product of their
environment they live in places where
the cheapest and most accessible foods
is peasant food
it's whole grains it's nuts it's greens
it's it's uh tubers
um so and
it's cheapest and most accessible and
they have these time-honored recipes to
make them taste good and their kitchens
are set up so they can make them easily
so of course they're going to eat that
it's a lot easier to eat that can you
know travel to a big city and buy
processed foods
they don't have these mechanized
conveniences in their houses
um
so they're they're not turning to some
you know power tool to do their work
they're
needing
uh bread by hand or grinding corn by by
hand they're doing garden work by hand
the the option to implode into their
homes onto their electronics isn't there
because
within a
day if you not showing up to
uh the village center or the party or
church somebody's knocking on your door
yeah
there's a certain expectation
and um nobody wakes up wondering what
their position is in their community
there's always a very clear sense of
purpose and sense of responsibility
um you know the the okinawans use this
word ikigai
people are starting to use that word a
lot sense of purpose and it really does
make a big difference when it comes to
longevity probably eight extra years of
life expectancy
but the purpose experience in blue zones
isn't the sort of follow your passion
purpose that we think of in america you
know we think well we we're going to
retire or you know we get we you know we
um i got some free time on my hand i'm
going to travel or i'm going to play
golf or
or
pursue knitting whatever it is
purpose in blue zones
is
is spliced with responsibility
so
when when people think of purpose it's
always connected to
um
putting the focus back on somebody else
it's making sure the younger generation
um
thrives it's it's making sure that the
community is taking care of making sure
certain practices are preserved
there's always an altruistic element to
purpose in the blue zones
when you look at these blue zones
pillars you know movement
plant-based plant-slant diet
uh faith
friendship connectivity all of these
things is
are they
are they relatively
evenly balanced they're certainly
independent they're they're
interdependent with each other but
is there one that stands out it you know
did you write this blue zone's kitchen
book because the diet component of it is
so important or how do you think about
how the interplay of all of those yes
they are definitely connected but the
most important variable there is eating
americans probably lose six years of
life expectancy eating the standard
american diet this is at middle age by
the way
overeating say a blue zones diet which
is largely beans whole grains greens
nuts and tubers you know and fruits and
vegetables as well so i'll spit out a
couple of the insights captured for blue
zones kitchen on how they eat
first of all they're cooking no matter
where you go they're only using about 20
recipes or 20 ingredients rather over
and over and over because they know how
to combine these ingredients to create a
symphonic deliciousness
but not a not a ton of different
crazy foods or superfoods no superfoods
except for beans beans is probably the
super food
number two they tend to consume all
their food in about an eight hour window
breakfast like a king lunch like a
prince dinner like a pauper number three
they tend to say
uh say something before the meal that
marks a punctuation between their busy
life and now we're slowing down to eat
like a prayer the adventists or the
sardinians or harahachibu which is a
confucian adage that the okinawans say
before every meal to remind themselves
to stop eating when their stomachs are
80 full
they tend to eat with their family
they tend to not have electronics in
their kitchen so they're not eating to
their favorite song or eating to their
favorite tv show
they
they tend to cook at home as opposed to
to going out
these are all things that
i i would argue add to the
um
ecosystem of eating that produces
long-lived people and the core of which
being this this
make knowing how to make plant-based
food taste delicious
the very clear lesson that we get from
blue zones is here's environments that
we know are
producing
the statistically longest lived and
healthiest populations and when i say
longest live i don't mean they have
better genes that are going to make them
lived 120 what i am saying is they're
avoiding
heart disease cancer diabetes and
dementia
the diseases that foreshorten your life
so they're getting the full 95 years or
so which is the capacity of the human
machine if you're listening to this
right now
your body is right to the to the
the extent we science understands the
human body your body's capacity is 95 if
you do all the right things these
populations are achieving that 95 year
mark better than any other population in
the world and they're doing it because
they live in the right environment
next up in our survey of longevity is
david sinclair phd who is one of the
world's leading scientific authorities
on aging and maybe even more importantly
how to slow its effects
david is a professor in the department
of genetics at harvard medical school
he's one of the scientific pioneers who
co-discovered the cause of aging for
yeast and in this clip david unpacks the
science behind what aging is and
provides insights into
what we can do about it
what do you think are the most important
things that people should be doing or
looking after on a daily basis to kind
of you know take out an insurance policy
against
aging given the current state of
knowledge and understanding that's well
put
we now know we all have the the power
with the scientific basis
to actually
live at least 15 years longer okay so
there are actually and i
talked about this i think on twitter
recently that there are there are five
things that are pretty obvious and easy
to do
uh that'll give you 15 years and that's
just off the top of of my head
things like you know exercise
the fasting don't eat too much eat the
right foods try to be uh plant-based
uh get sleep have social network
that gives you 15 years that's amazing
that's not even going
delving deep into my book which takes it
to another level of what the best
exercise and supplements probably are
about 80 percent of our lifestyle
um 80 of our health in old age is due to
our lifestyle and how we live right and
only 20 is genetic and actually that
that's done uh by studying twins who you
know some smoke some don't look
different do all this stuff
your genes are not your destiny that's
the good news so that what that means is
it's up to you and if you want to be
frail or to be honest dead at 80 go for
it we know how to do that
do everything that that the marketing
people want you to do eat the cake sit
on your fat house and watch movies
that'll get you there pretty quickly
yeah but fortunately you know in part
thanks to new media like this we can
actually
all talk about what we think are the
ways to extend lifespan and and not be
frail
in old age like my father i talk about
him a lot i'm very proud of him as a
beacon of hope
at 80 he's still running around like
he's 25 he's got no aches or pains
very sharp-minded using all sorts of
high-tech
um lifting more weights than i can
literally and our trainer who's
currently training the two of us
together
he says you know what uh
i think my dad was dead lifting or was
it a something like 180 pounds something
a lot and he said the last 80 year old
that i trained was was learning how to
get out of a chair he's also somebody
who's been on your kind of protocol for
a while at this point and to see him in
the gym at 80 like crushing it it's it's
very inspiring
well i i think most of us can achieve
that in life you know there will be
unlucky people that of course diseases
still hit us
but most of us are wasting our our lives
uh because we're we're basically not not
you but
most people uh don't think about their
longevity they think oh when i'm old
i'll deal with that when it comes but
now in early and midlife is the time to
invest because it'll pay off dividends
later in life
let's define our terms i mean what is
aging from your perspective
well i've come to
the conclusion that aging is a condition
i will be bold and say it should be
declared a disease
if you smoke it increases your chance of
getting lung cancer by about fivefold
and we all we worry about that we try to
we spend billions of dollars on on
trying to treat cancer and prevent
smoking
getting to the age of 60 increases your
chance of cancer by a thousand fold
okay
aging is the root cause of by far what
is the magnitude of all of these
diseases that we eventually get they're
not separate things aging is what causes
these and how many people do you know
that get heart disease and alzheimer's
in their 20s very few the reason is
because the body is young enough to
defend its fend off these diseases
so my approach to this is that
if we can figure out why we get old and
how to reprogram the body
the cells in the body to be young again
we won't get those diseases and even if
we have the disease those diseases the
body can heal itself
like we were 20 again
okay so then
when we age what is actually happening
on a cellular level
all right so we in the aging field have
come up with
uh eight
or nine
uh what we call the hallmarks of aging
the the underlying causes of aging from
telomere loss to mitochondrial decay to
proteins misfolding
but i think there's actually one of
those
pieces of the pie one of those eight or
nine that's
above all of them that rules them all
and this is
what i think is that the basis of what
i'm calling the information theory of
aging and what
we and and the team for sure deserves
credit for finding was that there's
a set of genes in yeast cells and also
in our bodies as well though at the time
we didn't know it
that
sense the environment so when a yeast
cell is hungry or it has too much
temperature change you make it hot you
make it really cold
uh or you subtract out some amino acids
it will live longer and that is because
it's activating a set of genes called
the sirtuins
and they're called surtourings because
their first yeast gene was called cer2
now what's key to this whole information
theory is that cer2
is an acronym
stands for silent information regulator
number two
so just a little bit about genetics
silent information is essentially a gene
that's switched off and and stays off
and in yeast
that's the genes that control whether
it's yeast cell is a male or female so
so too that gene was known already to
yeast biologists in the 1980s
to silence genes to keep them off
okay and what
the lab that i was in guaranty's lab
discovered is that if you mutate these
surgeons or two and so three so four
genes
the yeast cells live longer
but out came this silencing what we now
known as know as an epigenetic right
regulator and that was that blew
everyone away but it was very confusing
why would a gene
regulator have any impact on longevity
but what i think now is that the major
cause of aging
is a loss not of the genetic information
but the epigenetic information of the
body
the dna strand is
very tightly packaged in other proteins
called histones and those histones
come together very tightly
to silence genes so that's what the
sirtuins do they they bundle up the
genes so that they get switched off or
the histones might be spread out and
they allow the cell to read the gene and
that's what we call the epigenome it's
the system that
controls how the dna is packaged and
says to the cell these genes should be
on and these genes should be off because
dna is digital the epigenome
if you look at it is actually analog and
analog information is extremely subject
to noise over time
the main reason we switch to digital
but being analog means that it's very
hard to copy it's also very hard to
maintain in a pristine state over a
period of
two weeks for a yeasel or 80 years for a
human
and so i'm fairly convinced given the
work we've done over the last 10 years a
lot of it unpublished
that the reason we age is that it's the
analog information in the body that's
lost over time not the digital in the
same way that a compact disk has digital
information
and if you scratch it up you lose the
ability to read the right songs at the
right time right that's super
interesting
i think it's pretty clear that the food
we eat has a drastic impact on our
health and longevity
but what about periods of time sometimes
even longer periods of time than people
might even think possible when
we don't eat at all or in other words
can fasting have any impact on health
span
well dr alan goldhamer has the answer or
a answer i should say an iconoclastic
pioneer in his field dr goldhamer is the
founder of true north health center in
santa rosa california which is one of
the first and largest facilities in the
world that specializes in medically
supervised water only fasting
over the last few decades dr goldhamer
has successfully supervised more than 20
000 patient fasts and has seen lives
transformed wholesale
so in this clip from my discussion with
dr goldhamer he walks us through the
benefits of fasting and the power of a
whole food plant-based diet to prevent
and reverse the many chronic lifestyle
ailments that unnecessarily impair
or shorten the lives of millions of
people across the world
how good you can become in a sport may
largely be dependent on genetics and
luck how long you're going to live in
life may be largely dependent on
genetics and love but how well you're
going to live in the time you have left
may be dependent on what you put in your
mouth and the diet and lifestyle choices
that you make and so what we're trying
to explain to patients is you're not
going to live forever you're going to
die there's been
a hundred over 100 billion humans modern
humans born on the planet there's 7.3 or
4 billion alive today but there's only
been five well-documented people that'll
live past 117. so the thing is you're
not going to live forever but you don't
have to spend the average 9.6 years of
debility or 17 years in poor health that
the average american is spending you
know
giving up compromising the last decades
of life that could be your richest
decades of life because of chronic
degenerative diseases because we haven't
taken control of our diet sleep and
exercise patterns and that's what we're
trying to point is you may not be able
to live forever but you can reduce
dramatically the years of debility that
you have your vulnerability to
infectious disease your likelihood of
developing heart attack stroke and other
debilitating conditions that's where the
big payoff is
not living forever but living well until
you die having a good life and then
having a good death all right so how
does the fasting come in though
a pathway towards that so fasting is
interesting because
you're dealing with people that are
oftentimes addicted to the artificial
stimulation of dopamine in their brain
whether it's to drugs or dietary issues
fasting is a great way of breaking that
cycle it can be a very effective way of
getting the person to the point where
good foods taste good it's a great way
of lowering the blood pressure enough
you can eliminate the the medications
along with the chronic cough fatigue the
impedance and premature death that's
associated with them normalizing the
blood sugar levels so your insulin
levels normalize you don't have the
cravings and the binging and all the
other stuff that sometimes go along with
it or in autoimmune diseases oftentimes
pain
is significant inflammation swelling
people can't be active they can't
dissipate their attention they aren't
able to engage effectively and so when
you get people out of pain it's like an
epiphany experience and now the
motivation goes up it's hard to be
motivated to make diet lifestyle changes
when you feel like crap all the time but
when you get a taste of feeling good
again it's very motivating and now
oftentimes that's enough motivation to
help people overcome their addictions
and their tendencies the reality is i
found the most effective patients or
those are most motivated and motivations
that are the most powerful is pain
debility and fear of death yeah 100 the
only problem is you know a lot of these
people they get out of pain and they're
not fearing death anymore and then they
might slip slide a little bit because
they think i'm better now i don't have
to work quite so hard so you know
there's there's challenges on both sides
but yeah it's one thing to talk about
intermittent fasting or you know a
fasting mimicking protocol it's another
thing altogether to talk about a 40-day
water fast well that is a very extreme
moses david elijah
jesus in our patients right you know do
fasting it's interesting that fasting is
you know shows up in all these various
religious traditions isn't it
interesting the jews the genes the
hindus the muslims the buddhists the
christians all these religions that's
diametrically opposed on so many things
that are killing each other in the
street over disagreements they have one
thing in common and that's a tradition
about fasting because fasting changes
how you feel about yourself and the
world around you it can't help it you
know these um traditions resonate uh
throughout history and you know the
reality is perhaps is because that's
what works
so you
you approach fasting from a perspective
of of um weight management and also
disease prevention and reversal but
there's al also all this emerging
science around longevity and anti-aging
of course that's longo's you know
specific lens on this but
by dint of autophagy and all these other
you know
like sort of you know biomechanical
systems that are affected by fasting
there's now this whole world of research
opening up around prolonging life as a
result of this i actually think the
people that are going to turn out to get
the most benefit from fasting this one
in two week fast that we do with healthy
people is healthy people healthy people
that are looking to stay healthy too
for example to avoid vulnerability of
infectious disease to avoid the problems
that you know not waiting like my
brother did until he has a heart attack
but the people that are willing to use
it to prevent the problems from
beginning and interestingly enough i've
been communicating with walter long ago
recently about doing a joint study where
we're going to use his expertise and
access and our facility to do some look
not just at intermittent fasting but
long-term fasting and compare and
contrast and see what the very best bang
for the buck so to speak of is in terms
of taking healthy people and helping
them stay that way we've got a study
that's planned for next year looking
specifically exotic biomarker changes
with these dietary changes with fasting
and then trying to differentiate
how much fasting how frequently what's
the right combination that's all
relatively new
uh territory why is it that uh why 40
days or 21 days like what is it about
that extended period that's so important
well what we do is we want to fast as
short as possible but long enough to get
the problem resolved and so it's not
like we're setting out to try to beat
jesus in the in fasting duration
we don't go over 40 days generally
because if you keep the fasts under 40
days there's few metabolic complications
as you start getting into the really
long fasts the 60 days the 80 days the
longer fast that we're done in the past
it's a much more delicate balance in
terms of electrolyte balance and other
things and so
the guy that i trained with alec burton
in australia used to do fast as long as
100 days or longer walk me through the
experience of this journey that you see
with the typical patient i mean you're
demanding a lot of them they're going
through something they've never done
before like what is the
you know what it what is that like for
that individual when they're on day
three day 10 day 30
yeah so the first a few days of fasting
are actually the most difficult because
you're adapting off the
uh off of glucose metabolism into a fat
metabolism so the brain is changing
fuels from burning sugar to blurring
largely beta-hydroxybutyric acid which
comes from the ketone bodies from the
fat breakdown so there's an adjustment
there
you're detoxing oftentimes a lot
although we've learned to minimize the
effect of detoxification by getting
people to eat a fruit vegetable only
diet for a few days before we start
fasting that's made a huge difference so
they're not coming off caffeine
addiction at the same moment that
they're trying to adapt to the fast
they've already gotten that stuff out of
their system and that's actually the
most difficult stuff getting the
cigarettes the caffeine the alcohol all
the
meat fish foul eggs dairy plex processed
foods all the host of chemicals that
people are putting into their body with
over-the-counter prescription
medications so we've gone through a
wean-down process and then we start
fasting and their mouth may coat up and
taste like something crawled in there
and died and they may have some skin
rashes or elimination they may get mucus
discharged they may get
some vivid dreams they may have aches
and pains and they may have difficulties
with
all kinds of adaptive processes but they
go away and then something else comes
along and then it goes away and then it
becomes very empowering because they
realize that they're able to get through
this process that just because they had
a headache doesn't mean they have to
rush out and try to suppress those
symptoms of the pill it goes away the
body's able to heal itself
and then once you get into four or five
days of fasting the body's pretty well
acclimated to the fasting again at this
point there's no hunger people are going
to cooking demonstrations they're coming
to lectures they're going to the dining
room to socialize with people they're
five days ten days into a fast you think
oh my god you haven't eaten for 10 days
no i just enjoy being there that's not a
problem um so then um
depending on the patient sometimes they
start getting relief they're pain maybe
for the first time
in years the pain that they've been
suffering with is going away and they
may find that you know some people have
these chronic debilitating problems
start resolving things start falling off
tumors start shrinking they start
getting excited like oh maybe there's
something to this idea of the body
healing itself
and you know we're monitoring these
patients to go through the process and
then at some point you get to the point
where there's a limiting factor maybe
their electrolytes start to drop a
little bit or their energy is not
acceptable they're not able to maintain
accurate ambulation or maybe they've
just that's how much time they've got
because you know some people have jobs
and lives responsibilities so we only
have so much fun here for 40 days
so my life completely craters on the
outside but for many people this is an
intense epiphany experience because
they've got this intense education that
they're really open to they've seen
these other people sometimes what looks
to them like miracles going on because
they're seeing people that they have no
expectation that that could get well
getting well they're experiencing
themselves sometimes for the first time
you know a sense of empowerment because
they're able to actually reverse these
processes they were told nothing could
be done learn to live with it what do
they expect at their age that's just how
it is and now they're thinking wow
if they were wrong about that maybe
they're wrong about other things too and
they start you know looking at all
aspects of their life you know when
people first start exercising at first
it's not pleasant they got aches they
got pains they they're fatigued they're
not they're not getting the success they
can't do what they want but as they do
it they get to the point where not only
do they tolerate they're not just doing
it because they want to you know
maintain the weight or get the figure or
whatever it is they're doing is they
start realizing they're getting real
intrinsic benefit from engaging in this
consistent activity and now they don't
want to give it up
and i think the same thing happens when
people really get into a healthy
lifestyle and they're really exhausted
they don't want to go give it up and
feel like everybody else feels because
of some greasy slimy convenient food
they're willing to pay the price of
trying to do the planning and do what it
takes to try to ensure that they can get
their needs met just like i think people
that get into a regular exercise regime
uh realize that now this is so
beneficial they will literally structure
their schedules around making sure that
that's an important part of their
activity and the same thing happens with
sleep when you realize how important
sleep is to health and maintenance and
energy you start prioritizing that and
you don't compromise your sleep you
don't compromise your exercise and
hopefully you don't you learn to not
compromise your time lifestyle i tell
people here's what you need to do first
get enough sleep because it's your most
critical activity then engage in regular
exercise so you can dissipate the
tension you can build fitness and have
the time to prepare and eat healthy food
if there happens to be any time left
well fine you go to work
sorry to interrupt the flow we'll be
right back with more awesome but i want
to snag a moment to talk to you about
the importance of nutrition the thing is
most people i know actually already know
how to eat better and aspire to
incorporate more whole plants more
fruits vegetables seeds beans and
legumes into their daily routine sadly
however without the kitchen tools and
support very few end up sticking with it
so
because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly and
because i want everybody to experience
some version of what i've experienced we
decided to tackle and solve this very
common problem the solution we've
devised i'm proud to say is the plant
power meal planner our affordable
all-in-one digital platform that sets
you up for nutrition excellence by
providing access to thousands of highly
customizable super delicious and easy to
prepare plant-based recipes everything
integrates with automatic grocery
delivery and you get access to our
amazing team of nutrition coaches seven
days a week and many other features to
learn more and to sign up visit
meals.richrol.com and right now for a
limited time we're offering ten dollars
off an annual membership when you use
the promo code rr health at checkout
this is life-changing stuff people for
just a dollar seventy a week literally
the price of a cup of coffee again
that's
meals.richroll.com promo code rrhealth
for 10 off an annual membership all
right
let's get back to the show
there is no prescribable pharmaceutical
no magic pill available that will
instantly prolong our lives but
there is an often overlooked and
culturally undervalued tool for
longevity that just might surprise you a
counter-intuitive answer to our
overstimulated hyper-productive
lifestyles that is readily available to
everyone
what is that
it's
sleep sleep people
enter the renowned matthew walker a
scientist and former professor at
harvard medical school and current
professor of neuroscience at the
university of california berkeley and
one of the country's leading sleep
experts in this clip matthew will share
insights into the value of sleep the
connection between insomnia and disease
and why sleep is inseparable from
longevity
all stages of sleep are critical um no
one stage of sleep you can do without
without suffering detriment right
firstly what we know is that one out of
every three people that you pass on the
street is not getting the sleep that
they need so the cdc right now
recommends stipulates a minimum of seven
hours of sleep uh to maintain human
health yeah one of the one of the
striking things in the book that really
hit me was
the
relative lack of elasticity in the human
body in that just one night of
dysregulated sleep a week has much more
of a profound deleterious effect than
you would think you would think like
well i sleep pretty well most nights but
you know
once a week like my stuff got screwed up
but you know i'll recover
but the downstream implications of just
a little bit of dysregulation are much
more serious than one
one would suspect yeah i mean a good
example is another study where if you
take healthy adults and you limit them
to just four hours of sleep for a single
night
the next day we see a 70 drop in
critical anti-cancer fighting immune
cells 7-0
called natural killer cells
now today
you and i have both produced cancer
cells more than likely
what prevents those cells from becoming
and manifesting as the condition that we
call cancer
is in part these critical
cancer fighting immune cells natural
killer cells
that is a dramatic state of immune
deficiency and it happens quickly after
just one bad night of sleep and i think
about this all the time when i wake up
after an amazing night of sleep and then
my experience throughout the day is
optimal
and then the following night i have a
degraded version of that and i wake up
and i think why can't i just why can't
we figure out a way to replicate this
day in and day out without
pharmaceutical intervention like i'm
trying to do all the right things and
yet it is so elusive and part of that
yes is age because when you're a
teenager you can just you know fall
asleep in an instant and seem to get a
good night's sleep no matter what
but i'm constantly thinking about like
how do you figure this out and master it
because if you could it would literally
change everybody's lives yeah and you
know if you take the reverse of that we
know you know starting with this
recommended sweet spot of between seven
to nine hours a night going in the
downward direction there's a very simple
truth which is that the shorter your
sleep the shorter your life
short sleep predicts or cause mortality
right which is which is so ironic given
that you know the hustle culture you
know it's all about maximizing those
daylight hours and i'll sleep when i'm
dead right i'm just working that death
yeah it's you know it's mortally unwise
advice anyone who tells you that um but
to me i think
you know sleep
sleep could be seen as the swiss army
knife of health you know whatever
ailment that you're facing sleep
normally has a tool in the box that can
help
and so for me i think the
the shangri-la is perhaps less about
trying to elongate lifespan sorry um
lifespan sorry
then it is really about prolonging
people's health span
because when you ask most people that's
what they really want when they're
trying to sort of you know live a clean
healthy lifestyle lifestyle they don't
want to life with disease and sickness
but when you are starting to short
change your brain and your body of sleep
that's what you're inviting
you know and the elastic band of sleep
deprivation will stretch only so far
before it snaps
and if you fight biology
normally you lose and the way you know
you've lost is disease and sickness yeah
the the human hubris over all of this
though is something to behold because we
always think we can find a you know an
end run around these things and as
beautiful and and magnificent
as the scientific method is it tends to
be very binary in its approach right so
if x then y
i'm controlling for variables but when
you're dealing with systems that are so
complex
my sense is that oftentimes
it leads to unintended negative
consequences right like this pill and
you'll sleep well but we're not
realizing or looking at all these other
things that are occurring and it isn't
until much later when researchers like
yourself
can pull pull the covers on that and say
this was not such a good idea yeah
polakova's known no pun intended right
right right you know but but i think
you're right
there is a very understandable again i i
don't want to sort of be finger wagging
or chastise people if you don't know the
science of sleep you know i would be
just as as unknowing
but it took mother nature 3.6 million
years to put this essential thing called
you know a seven to nine hour sleep need
in place
to think that with hubris or arrogance
that we could come along and within five
or ten years if we're you know medical
sort of forcing medical residents to go
through these ridiculous sort of
schedules or you know if you're in some
other professional industry that you can
just find a way to hack that system
is unfortunately misfounded during deep
sleep our heart rate decelerates our
vascular system our vessels start to
relax you can think of deep sleep like
the very best form of blood pressure
medication that you could ever wish for
we also see that it's during that
nighttime phase when we drop levels of
cortisol which otherwise if left in high
concentrations is a stress related
chemical it's an adaptive chemical too
we all need cortisol but if you're just
chronically high in cortisol
that is you know deathly for your
cardiovascular system
and sleep will actually ratchet down
that level also sleep will quiet the
fight or flight branch of your nervous
system it's called the sympathetic
nervous system which i think is terribly
named it's anything but sympathetic you
know it's agitating it's
and it's during deep sleep that we
actually shift over from that fight or
flight branch to the more quiescent
calming branch called the
parasympathetic nervous system
and so now we can start to understand
why we see risks for heart attack risks
for cardiovascular
disorder we published a paper um a
couple of months ago demonstrating that
short sleep and particularly not just
short sleep but also fragmented sleep
and this is i think another important
point that we've learned in the most
recent years it's not just about the
quantity of sleep
it's also about the quality of that
sleep and we found that people who had
fragmented sleep
had a higher likelihood of their blood
vessels become becoming hard it's what
we call atheroscle sclerosis the
hardening of the blood vessels which can
then be a direct pathway to
cardiovascular disease and heart attack
as well
that's interesting
um and is that is there a sense of
um where that falls in the pecking order
of importance when you compare it to
nutrition or exercise or these other
kind of contributing or ameliorating
factors with respect to heart disease
it's just as heavy a hitter you know if
you look at the combination of quantity
and quality of sleep and you look at the
effect sizes the you know it's right up
there
um
you can almost play the game and and i
don't mean to do this because
i'm someone who pays i'm
very dedicated to a practice of physical
activity and exercise you know i'm not
quite at your level but um and i eat
very cleanly i i too am uh i'm a
vegetarian um
so i respect those things because i know
how utterly important they are for my
health span and my lifespan
but
i can do a thought experiment where i
say i take you rich role and i'm going
to deprive you of either exercise for 24
hours of food for 24 hours of water for
24 hours or of sleep for 24 hours
and sleep yeah no there's no comparison
but yeah a country mile will dwarf the
physiological and mental deficits that
come by way of that i think the only
other thing that's perhaps
will overtake sleep is oxygen you know
if i starve you functioning
you'll you will
i hold my hands up i lose out to oxygen
right right but but you've said often
that you know when you think of the
pillars of health
sleep isn't a pillar it's the foundation
upon which all these other pillars are
erected essentially right yeah i used to
think it was i thought about it pillar
but then you know the more i've done
this research over the years the more i
realized that i was wrong
i want to be clear about one point and
that is that longevity isn't really just
about living as long as possible because
the true objective is to
live as vibrantly and as energetically
as possible for as long as possible
and my next guest the esteemed walter
longo phd has devoted his life to this
endeavor
one of the world's leading scientific
authorities on the subject of longevity
dr longo is the director of the usc
longevity institute as well as the
program on longevity in cancer at ifom
in milan both of which
focus on developing a better scientific
understanding of the fundamental
mechanisms of aging and disease
here dr longo shares his thoughts on
aging and many insights gleaned from his
scientific research
what is
aging what causes it what exacerbates it
and what have you discovered can perhaps
uh
slow it down
yes so
aging is actually
i started the book by talking about that
aging is actually not a bad thing right
i mean violins age age and they get
better right and and marathon runners
they get better at least for a while as
they age and then uh you know maybe the
big performance uh
from marathon runner peaks around 32-35
which is very different from other
athletes um senescence is really the
word that that deals with
changes that are detrimental so
accumulation of damage and other uh
dysregulation that leads to dysfunction
right so that's the the worst in essence
usually we use aging because people
everybody
uh understands that word better so it's
fine to use aging but uh yeah so as time
goes by uh systems um become accumulate
damage um and they start becoming
dysfunctional why does the body
suddenly become less than less adept at
repairing that damage
well i mean
there are a lot of theories of aging and
a lot of people
most people have focused on the aging
part itself
i
come up with a term which i call
juventology or juventology
and the difference is that i focus on
what is the program that keeps you young
versus or what is the process that makes
you all right so it's very different
right so gerontology versus juventology
is sort of like the study and science of
health versus the study and science of
disease which is really the modical the
model of western medicine yes yes in a
sense i think so because if you're
studying um
things going wrong aging right then you
focus on the deterioration so for
example if you think of a car and that's
one of the pillars that i talk about in
the book you you can study the tires and
you can say okay i'm going to learn
everything about the rubber how the
rubber gets older and older and how to
make it not get older and older but i
can come around with uventology and say
why are you worried about that
just change your tires
do 50 000 miles and put a new set of
tires on now all of a sudden all the
research you can see how it's pointless
right
uh you just have to find out how to
replace it right so you got to figure
out how the body can produce new tires
right which gets into this stem cell
regeneration exactly you do so what is
the structure that you set up to try to
determine what keeps the cell young or
what can sort of increase its longevity
yeah so the the beginning it was
use this simple organism and use genetic
tools at the time were only available
for yeast for baker's yeast right so for
example we are one of our first studies
that we publish in science
in the science journal
was
let's delete every single gene in the
genome which is about 6000 genes and see
which one is becomes most protected
against toxins right multiple toxins and
then the
the hypothesis was if something is super
protected against damage it's going to
be protected against aging and that
worked out very well and that led to the
identification was probably now
recognized as the
most important uh pro-aging path which
is the tor assist kinase pathway
and um and and so there was one strategy
use the tools genetic tools that we had
and the other one was because i was in
the wall for lab
and we had some people
lots of people working on on the on the
molecular biology of aging and the
molecule biology of yeast not aging
nobody cared about aging at that time
um
but uh
for example upstairs i had somebody
called fujitaminoy and he was working on
undress and we the field that described
our wrath uh reacted or was activated by
sugar right so then i started i came out
of the wall for lab i say if sugar
uh activate grass and color restriction
extends the lifespan of all these
organisms it must be
that if i delete rest
the east is going to live longer so this
is a biased approach versus what i said
earlier which is completely unbiased and
sure enough you know now
they live a lot longer they live two or
three times longer just by deleting with
this sugar
gene so now
the taurus is kinase is the protein
pathway and the
peak eras pka is the sugar pathway right
you delete both of them you get 10-fold
lifespan extension wow and then you then
step it up and and apply this to a rat
population
yeah then then you uh apply it to a in
another case a mouse population also
knowing um that the data from from from
cynthia kenyon gary ravikon and others
in worms and flies right which was
matching so everything was starting to
make sense that was all aligned so tor
was causing aging in all these organisms
if you activate it and if you did
protein restriction
the organism live longer right so just
protein restriction
um so
yes so then you do the working in mice
uh
and then uh of course you do the work uh
with nutrition and say well if having
if deleting the protein gene and the
sugar gene makes the organism live
longer uh what if i just remove sugar
and proteins and then you go in proteins
you say well do i need to remove all
proteins maybe not maybe just certain
amino acids that are contained in
proteins so we remove serine trionene
and valine three amino acids and show
that those were the ones the major ones
that control
the tor gene right so yeah so then we
started really having a much
more sophisticated understanding of all
the network the controls aging in yeast
and mice
but also
understanding of the nutrients within
food that controls the genes that
control aging you deduce from that what
and how does that inform like the next
chapter
well
from that we we deduced that
it works right it's not a mouse or a
yeast uh finding this this is this is
going after
cellular protection multi-system
cellular production across the board so
so then um
these mice that could get to 50 longer
life but have health for the cancers and
protection of diabetes from prediction
for inflammation production from
cognitive decline their brain work
better and longer and we also show that
for the humans so now all of this uh is
possible you're starting to say well
we don't have to be this
in a western world of
living long very sick now you know we
used to live a little bit shorter and
healthier now we live longer sicker
and uh um we can live longer healthier
so the opposite of what we are obtaining
now so now we're keeping people alive
with lots of drugs and lots of
intervention yeah the idea that
extending longevity will only extend the
period of time in which you're sick is
the paradigm you're trying to upend yeah
we want to turn it completely around so
not only
we don't go to higher because of course
as soon as you start saying we want to
make people live 20 years longer to 110
let's say 30 years longer than now right
uh people are going to say no absolutely
not because they think of all the people
that they know right they're all sick
old folks home the whole time you know
unable to walk yeah so but if you look
at emma morano who at 112 could still
live in in her house alone right i mean
she didn't live alone but she could have
if she wanted to i mean she had people
that came
but i think in 120 506 she was alone
leaving alone
and
yeah and also if you saw salvador caruso
110 you think that's pretty good
named one of the top 100 longevity
leaders in the world sergey young is an
xprize foundation board member
the founder of the 100 million dollar
longevity vision fund and a development
sponsor of the age reversal xprize which
is a global competition designed to find
a cure for aging you heard that right
he cure
in this next clip sergey shares a
profound truth and that truth is that
technology can extend our lives but we
have to create lives that we want to
extend
the real secret to longevity isn't the
secret it's about what we're creating
here and now
how we're living our lives on a daily
basis and this is the foundation for
what sergey calls growing young but i'll
let him explain further
on top of of
everything in here one thing we haven't
gotten do yet
in this discussion around longevity
isn't just
arresting the aging process it's this
idea of i mean it's literally the title
of your book like growing young like the
reversal of aging so can you kind of
parse those two things when you say
growing young like what exactly are you
talking about yeah so
um remember what we started is like
average lifespan on earth uh increased
from what 35 to like or at least in
developed countries from 35 to like 75
years but then the upper limit of
uh lifespan is still the same it's
somewhere around 120 years yeah so the
the oldest person on earth was this
beautiful french woman who died i think
back in 1999 in the age of 122 years and
this has been unchanged through the
whole history
so
uh then the question is um
how do we change that
and so for the way we've done we
increase our lifespan and health span
has been avoiding early deaths but
that's like the only thing that we've
done and even the focus of today
discussion is like well let's just not
die from cancer let's not die from heart
disease from diabetes we're facing
actually the next wave and next barrier
which is neurogenerative disease comes
which
come in a later stage of our life
somewhere around 80s or 90s
which we still need to solve but it's
again it's just so the average lifespan
increase because we're avoiding early
death so that's
that's the modus operandi a lot of those
stats are driven by infant mortality
exactly right exactly well that's that's
like the biggest uh
problem that we've been solving um so
but what what what is happening with the
technologies and and science
breakthroughs which are
uh available to us today and which is in
in like a working process today
we will soon have an ability to reverse
aging even like there was a very small
studies done with you know eight people
who actually managed to reverse their
aging based on set of biomarkers but a
very small number but agai and again
it's it sounds impossible and ridiculous
today but this is actually happen you
can grow young you can
change your set of biomarkers to be
younger like even today
like when i st when i had my staring
story when i'd rejected the idea of
taking the pill till the rest of my life
and change my diet became plant-based
doing physical exercises
taking
omega-3 and there's like even a vegan
version of that available right um so
you can be vegan and take in different
supplements um i reduce my biological
age by probably three to five years
so that's this is already happening we
just have this lifestyle intervention
and this will be
contributed and complemented by our
ability to influence genetic diseases or
our genetic setup our ability to regrow
and replace organs actually the most the
two most difficult ones is actually
brain and heart
isn't it symbolic
and
or having longevity and appeal right we
have so many um
um longevity and and age-related disease
kind of um drug candidates at the moment
like metformin generic drug has been
there for 50 60 years pretty safe we
still need to run a trial whether what
is that what is it um in terms of
creating uh
age reversal effect right or life
extension in fact but this is still uh
uh in in development stage but again
there's it's a lot of ideas how we can
reverse our aging and some of these
species on earth they don't have an
aging process so
the way they die is like metaphorically
like you know being hit by a bus right
so there's no in terms of our biological
setup we don't necessarily need to
to age but again and this and i do think
it was the theme of our conversation
today before
embracing technology and science of age
reversal there's much bigger issues that
we need to solve
yeah create a life that we want to
extend yeah 100
we like to talk a lot about the minutia
or the one percent that's gonna
you know some supplement that we can
take but in truth the real mover here is
how you're living your life on a daily
basis exactly and it's not sexy it's not
you know there's no there's no hack
involved with that it's just you know
good habits it's everyday practiced
every single day change your mentality
rather than taking responsibility and
changing the world changing your health
you just like sit and wait until
something magical will happen and i'm a
little bit against that i'm also i i
also think i'm chemical engineer by my
first degree so that's why
you know i just rejected the idea of you
know having statins for the rest of my
life and this is where my
longevity journey started i just do
believe that a lot of things need to be
tested
in a proper way before we can
uh embrace that and in the meantime we
just need to look at the levers that we
can uh
actually control today yeah and we can
change today so i i i think the downside
of believing in like magic peel or magic
supplement is that it's just another
excuse for us uh to be
irresponsible yeah divorcing you from
responsibility yeah i would agree with
that
if certain animal species can live
extraordinarily long lives then why
can't humans well our next speaker on
longevity wants to answer that question
enter peter diamandis peter is best
known as the founder and executive
chairman of the xprize foundation
and executive founder of singularity
university over the course of his
storied career peter has started over 20
companies in the areas of longevity
space travel venture capital and
education
in this clip peter explains the
intriguing concept of something called
longevity escape velocity
and gives a prediction as to when
scientists will reach it
how long before you think we reach what
you've talked about as
achieving longevity escape velocity
maybe like describe what that is
so
uh
today
science is having breakthroughs
uh
that are extending your life every year
and on the average for every year alive
science extends your life for about a
quarter of a year
uh there is a point and ray kurzweil
talks about it
extensively
and and ray wrote the the preface of our
book he's one of my mentors one of the
you know greatest thinkers on
exponential technologies he's my
co-founder at singularity university
and uh
he's i asked him when do you think we're
going to reach longevity escape velocity
which is the point that for every year
you're alive science is extending your
life for greater than a year right sort
of a departure point
and his answer about when we'll get
there uh he said is uh
about 12 years that's his guess now
if someone else said it i wouldn't give
it that much credence but if you google
ray kurzweil's um
accuracy on his predictions
it's like 86
i mean the guy is extraordinary in his
predictions of the future
and then i was in a conversation with
george church
who also write about extensively in the
book and and i asked george when do you
think we're gonna you know george is a
professor of genomics at harvard medical
school same as david sinclair and their
fantastic friends and collaborators
and uh george said uh within the next 15
years
wow and so i'm like
that's kind of insane right so assuming
let's assume for a moment that that's
correct
15 years from now give or take
we'll be able to
every year that you live there will be
an incremental uh
uh
additional to your life's healthcare
yeah sufficient enough such that
the perpetuation of life would seem to
never cease yeah it's like um
you know we have a 24 000 uh
uh mile diameter
uh or circumference of the planet and if
you're in a jet going at a thousand
miles an hour westward the sun never
sets mm-hmm right and that's that and so
if you go faster the sun will rise
and so it's somewhat similar in that
regard and it gets you thinking which is
um
you know to use a phrase from one of
rey's books fantastic voyage
it's living long enough to live forever
now let's put aside the idea of living
forever as a moment but
uh
how long can we live
when i was in medical school years ago
rich i remember watching a uh a tv show
on long-lived sea life
and i wasn't you know didn't have much
time for for tv i would basically just
watch star trek whenever i could which
was my sort of uh vitamin dosage
and what i learned was that certain
species of sea life like the bowhead
whale
large mammal
can live for 200 years
and uh greenland sharks can live for 500
years you know sea turtles similar
multi-hundred year lifespan and so the
question is if they can live that long
why can't we right and i remember
thinking it's either gonna be a hardware
problem or a software problem and we're
gonna have the tools to fix that and i
think
we're on the precipice of that
and what and and from a philosophical
point of view like that conjures up
a conversation around the
the appropriateness of all of it does
not i mean you're somebody who's always
been
very optimistic
you've written
a couple books where you kind of canvass
these emerging technologies and you
characterize them in very favorable
terms uh so you're not one to be prone
to dystopian
you know
uh scenarios um but i can't help but
think like in the event that you know
perhaps we could live to something like
200 years
like what would that mean like how does
that impact our psychology as a species
how does it let's
think about risk how does that impact
overpopulation
on a planet of you know decreasingly
limited resources et cetera so how are
you wrapping your head around all right
i know you've got a whole open store i
love it uh so um first of all a study
came out six months ago out of done by
uh lens school of business oxford and
harvard that looked at the impact of
extending
uh the lifespan
by just one year of every human on the
planet
the economic impact is 38 trillion
dollars the global economy
of being able to keep you and me in the
game a year longer so it's a massive uh
positive impact to the global economy
i'm gonna want to keep people in the
game and why do people stop working
because
they're in pain
or they're tired they don't have the
energy
and so but if you can if you can have
the vitality the aesthetics the
cognition the mobility
uh at 100 years old that you had at 50
or 60
you know it's an amazing time to be
alive
i can't help but think
if you could live to 200 the possibility
certainly exists that you would have
multiple partners across that period of
time yeah
multiple families like i had a whole
family with two kids with this person
and now i'm gonna have two kids with you
could do that three or four times over
and multiple careers
you know three or four times over you
know the reality is that uh our
existence our societal structure our
laws
are built around a very different age
you know we don't have a true democracy
of a representative democracy because
the communications didn't exist back you
know hundreds of years ago to be able to
count everybody's vote but they do now
um
and
uh you know the idea of social social
security
um was designed and developed when the
average lifespan was like 55.
you know
you would retire
go on social security you know 18 months
later you were dead
right uh and so all of this is changing
and you know for the financial advisors
listening to us or the people who are
dependent upon financial advisors
making sure you have enough money
if you're going to add 20 or 30 healthy
years
is an important conversation to have and
it's not being had sufficiently
because i think
this is the direction that we're heading
longevity escape velocity is kind of a
fun exciting idea to ponder but i'm not
sure how it applies to our lives on a
daily basis there are other things that
drive our attention and focus things
like heart disease depression autoimmune
disorders and how about at the top of
that pyramid
stress stress is a big one and according
to my next guest dr rongan chatterjee
it's at the heart of 70 to 90 of
conditions treated by primary care
doctors in regard to longevity the truth
is that bodies under chronic stress will
deteriorate more rapidly than those that
are not and in the following clip dr
chatterjee explains the science behind
stress and how to properly manage it to
promote a longer healthier life
i feel like the word stress is used very
cavalierly like wow we're all stressed
i'm stressed out i'm anxious or whatever
but perhaps it might be
um beneficial to
like define the term like when we say
stress like what do we actually mean and
what is happening biologically
physiologically in the body when we are
under this form of duress
i mean
it is a perception it is perception when
your body feels that it's under threat
that it is in danger that fundamentally
is what i think stress is
now how do you explain that
between 70 and 90 percent of all
conditions that a primary care doctor
sees in any given day is in some way
related to stress that's bananas that is
bananas but
i'm going to explain
why i think
it is quite easy to understand when you
understand what the stress response is
so let's go back again
two million years right two three
whatever we go back a couple of million
years ago and understand how our stress
response evolved so
we were again in our hunter-gatherer
community
getting on with our business doing what
we need to do and a wild predator is
attacking or approaching
we get scared in an instant
our stress response kicks into gear so
what happens then well the series of
physiological changes start to take
place that are designed to keep us safe
so i can't list them all but let's go
through it through some of them your
blood sugar starts to rise
great that means you're going to deliver
more glucose to your brain that is
fantastic in that in that threat
scenario
your blood pressure starts to go up so
you can deliver more oxygen to your
brain
your amygdala that's the emotional part
of your brain right that becomes hyper
reactive so you are literally hyper
vigilant for all the threats around you
your blood starts become more prone to
clotting so that if you were to get
attacked by that lion and that predator
you're not going to bleed to death your
blood's going to clot that's going to
keep you safe these are very very smart
complex mechanisms that are designed to
keep us safe the problem is
quite simply
is that now in the 21st century many of
us are having our stress responses
activated
not to wild predators
but to our daily lives to our email
inboxes to our to-do lists
to the fact that we've got competing
demands at work to the fact that um two
parents are working and someone's trying
to rush home to pick up the kids the
fact that actually we're living separate
from our family so we're having to do
all the child care ourselves we don't
have grandparents around us so the fact
that we may have elderly parents now
we're looking after as well as looking
after a young family for many of us
that is activating our stress response
so what happens well those mechanisms
are so helpful to us in the short term
they start to become problematic
blood sugar going up is fine for 30
minutes if your blood sugar is going up
day in day out
well that leads to fatigue obesity high
blood pressure and ultimately type 2
diabetes just from being stressed and i
go back to saying what i said before
what the whole conversation around
health is dominated by diet and
movements talk about type 2 diabetes
it's all about which dietary tribe you
subscribe to i can tell you that stress
is a very very key player when it comes
to your blood sugar and i have put many
cases of toxic diabetes since remission
yes i changed their diet for sure but
when the diet plateaued the way i got
the blood sugar lower was by addressing
their stress levels so blood sugar
problem helpful in the short term
harmful in the long term blood pressure
again same thing great if you're running
away from a tiger great if you're in
your spinning class in the gym it's an
appropriate response to that stressor
but if that's happening to your email
inbox that's a problem
what about your emotional brain right
the amygdala i just said
when you are trying to escape a predator
you become hyper vigilant to all the
threats around you that is appropriate
if you go to downtown la tonight and it
is dark and you are walking down a dark
street and you think somebody is
following you you know what you want
your amygdala to go on high alert you
want to be hyper vigilant to all the
threats around you
if that's happening day in day out to
your life
that's what we call anxiety
right so suddenly
this very complex mechanism when you
simplify it right down
we can start to see why
up to 90 of what i see as a doctor is in
some way related to stress but
what about the things that it switches
off right we've spoken a bit about
relationships so
libido is a big problem these days
i've been practicing for nearly 20 years
i'm seeing more cases of low libido now
than i've ever seen
not a week goes by where i don't see a
young male in their 20s complaining of
low libido this was not happening even
five years ago certainly in my practice
there are many factors to consider but
stress is probably the biggest in my
view
again go back 2 million years you are
running away from a threat
in that moment
you need to prioritize survival
you do not need to be able to chill out
and procreate with your partner right so
your body switches it off right it it it
all it almost sounds overly simplistic
but i love simplicity because when you
understand it simply you start to
realize hey i understand now why anxiety
why low memory by poor concentration
white insomnia why low libido why
hormonal problems why obesity why type 2
diabetes can all have stress as a key
player
gut problems right last mintel survey in
the uk
showed us that 80 percent of uk adults
have complained of some form of gi
problem in any given year
right now
food of course is a factor
but i would argue that stress is a
bigger factor because what happens
again just like libido if you're running
away from a lion you don't need to be
able to digest food which gets switched
off just like that
it's it's a time fraught with problems
pressures external pressures things that
we feel that we have to do
there are so many things that we can do
but the the thing that is rising to the
surface of me now
is
think about downtime
right
we need downtime
we thrive on downtime our brains thrive
on downtime
you simply cannot
get up
go on your phone consume
watch what the world is giving you
reacting go to after work drinks go to
all these family engagements come back
lie in bed consume more you simply just
cannot do that without there being a
consequence you will be accumulating
micro stress does after micro stressors
and you will go over and it will lead to
family arguments it will lead to a row
with your partner it will lead to you
getting uh stressed out at work and
falling out with your boss
it is all the consequence of that
framework of micro stress doses and
where is your stress threshold you need
to minimize the micro stress doses and
you need to take active steps
to
increase your resilience so
well let's call it simple you mentioned
a morning routine right
i'm a huge fan of morning routines and
the framework i create for people is a
morning routine has three m's and the
way i see it
mindfulness movement and mindset
so if you want a morning routine you
don't know where to start think about
those three m's now you can personalize
them to your own life if you have got an
hour in the morning great if you've got
five minutes you can still do it in five
minutes
just the act of having five minutes to
herself in that morning
actually transforms the rest of her day
have some time to yourself
really be mindful of that and if you
find a morning we've seen helpful start
there now the next thing i'd probably
say to people is
think about how much you've moved right
yes we know physical activity is
important
but
fundamentally if we go back to too many
years ago when we think about our stress
response
what is the stress response designed to
do
it is priming us
for physical activity
nowadays the stresses are coming in such
a way like you know we're sitting on our
butts
at our desk and our email inbox is
stressing us out or the fact that
actually
oh man i am exhausted today but everyone
at work is going out tonight and then my
sister's flying into town tonight oh man
i just want to go to sleep right so i
would say have you moved enough just ask
yourself have you moved if you haven't
just make it a priority every day to do
something even if it's a 10 minute walk
at lunch time put your phone down go
outside for 10 minutes and you will
start
to burn off that stress in your body but
those are two simple things right when
you're traveling if you're traveling to
go and see your family right
and this applies not in the holiday
season as well that people are traveling
to work and they're getting stressed out
use that travel time
to really to really look after your
mental health right don't put the news
on don't listen to what trump has just
tweeted right own your mental space own
what's going on in there use that time
to listen to relaxing music listen to an
inspiring podcast
pull up the calm meditation app on your
phone and
put your headphones in and meditate for
10 minutes i am not asking you to do
three hours of yoga every day even
though that will help you right i'm
asking you to just think about have i
given myself a bit of time today
if you are getting stressed out at a
party your family are there your mother
is stressing you out right your
mother-in-law let's say you know or
whatever
check in with your breath
it's a cliche it is the biggest cliche
just breathe
if people understood what breathing
actually does
on a fundamental physiological level we
would all be practicing every day
breathing is information for your body
when you're feeling stressed when you've
got deadlines that you're working away
for you will not realize but your
breathing will change
you you'll start to breathe more from
your chest than your diaphragm you'll
breathe quicker your breasts will be
more shallow and what does that do that
sends messages to your brain that i am
in danger that there is a problem and
that gets you in a viciously where you
start to breathe faster now the great
news about that is is that you can very
easily change that situation if you
consciously
change your breathing you can change
your physiology so if that's happening
you're at a party uh whatever there's a
work do you know what maybe go to the
restroom
or go go outside and just for two
minutes
breathe
do the three four five breath if you
don't like that one do a box breath
where you breathing for four
hold for four breathe out for four hold
for four i guarantee
if you do that for one minute or two
minutes
you will feel calmer and the way you
deal with that situation
will absolutely
it will change you will you will be less
reactive
what if we reimagined aging not as
something to fear but as something
aspirational
well in this inspired clip of our master
class on longevity we reframe aging as a
sacred phase of life to be
celebrated an opportunity an opportunity
to share accrued wisdom
channel it into a second act and
leverage it to make your life and
relationships more meaningful
leading us on this philosophical journey
is chip conley chip is a highly
accomplished individual but i want to
draw attention to his latest endeavor as
the founder of something called the
modern elder academy which is the first
midlife wisdom school
dedicated to transforming aging
here is chip conley
what's fascinating is there's a societal
narrative on aging and then there's a
personal narrative the societal
narrative is
if you can survive your midlife crisis
around 45 or 50 on the other side of
that you have disease and decrepitude
and then you die right and the reality
is the personal narrative on people's
aging is very different than that and
there's something called the u-curve of
happiness it's gotten a lot of social
science research uh attention
and the idea of it is once you hit
around 47.2 although your mileage may
vary
um with each passing decade after that
you get happier and happier so you're
happier in your 50s than your 40s 60s
and 50s 70s and 60s and you start to see
some leveling out and a decline in
happiness around the last two or three
years of your life so if you're living
to a hundred and maybe who knows how
long he'll live you know he's probably
still on the stride going up yeah but
what's so strange is the gap between the
personal narrative which is actually
people do get happier as after age 50
and the societal narrative which is you
know it's all you're all downhill after
about age 40. the way we think about
aging is so
unhealthy it's like this black hole like
you know there's and i know you've
talked about this there's childhood
there's adulthood and then and then what
like what happens for 40 or 50 years
like we don't really talk about it you
dubbed it elderhood um but
short of housing people in these
horrible you know sort of assisted
living situations
we haven't really created any kind of
modern
forward thinking um
kind of uh
programming around like how to get the
most out of these many decades later in
life you know if you're going to live
till 90 which is you know very likely
for a lot of us my parents are 84.
neither one of them has been a huge
athlete um
and they're on a six week vacation right
now at age 84. so if you live until 90
and you're 54 which is a little bit
younger than you um you're halfway
through your adult life if you start
counting at age 18.
and we don't think about life that way
we very much underestimate how much
adult life we have ahead of us we also
um overestimate how long we're going to
be an invalid
and there's something called compressed
morbidity in the medical field and it
means that in essence the the time of
your life when you're sort of on the
verge of death
is a much shorter period on average than
it used to be
so you've got you know what what uh mary
katherine bateson would call is she
calls it the midlife atrium she says
that
having additional life
um having additional years because
longevity in the year 1900 was 47 on
average and by the year 2000 it was 77.
she says all of those additional years
are not like having extra bedrooms in
the backyard of your house like you're
you're old longer no she says it's like
having a midlife atrium
and the midlife atrium means there's
light and air and additional space
happening in the middle of your life so
you're in mid-life longer and yet we
have very little in the way of society
um resources tools or even
thinking around what midlife is supposed
to be yeah one of the
critical kind of tools that you leverage
at the modern elder academy that i want
to hear a little bit more about is just
getting really clear on what your
mindset is so that you can begin the
process of deconstructing it and perhaps
you know telling yourself a new story
yeah well so there's four key um pillars
of our curriculum the first one is
reframing aging helping people to see
that maybe their best life their best
years are ahead of them right can this
be aspirational it can be and you know
some things get better with age i i love
that your your listeners and your
community is very much about keeping the
body alive and but but you don't you're
certain things get actually better with
age you know your emotion your emotional
intelligence grows with age
your spiritual awareness grows with age
so there's a lot of things actually get
better with age and yes if you work on
your body and your health and your
nutrition it might get better with age
as well
uh you're a great example of that
so
there's that reframing aging then
there's mindset so there's growth and
fixed mindset we're big fans of carol
dweck's work at stanford and so a fixed
mindset is when you tend to think of
life as i'm here to prove myself and i
define success as winning
the problem if you have that point of
view as you get older
is
you stop playing the games you can't win
and that means your your sandbox gets
smaller and smaller and as it gets
smaller
you actually get more bored because
you're not trying new things so moving
from a fix to a growth mindset means
moving from proving yourself to
improving yourself and
instead of focused on focusing on
winning
you focus on learning
becca levy is the one who actually in
many ways our program is built on her
work from yale
she was able to show that when you shift
a person from a negative to a neutral
mindset i'm sorry from a negative to a
positive mindset on aging
you give them 7.5
additional years of life
what
it's actually more life than if someone
stopped smoking at age 50 or if they
stop started exercising at age 50.
so the public health benefit of shifting
a mindset around aging has a greater
benefit to society and people are
happier
and yet we have psas left and right
about how we should stop smoking and how
we should
start exercising we have no psas around
how to reframe aging
one of the questions we ask at mea is
what is it that you know now or have you
done now that you wish you had known or
done 10 years ago
think about that for a moment
and then ask yourself 10 years from now
what will you regret if you don't learn
it or do it now
and this is how i started to learn how
to surf at age
um because i live on a beach near a surf
break somewhat famous one and i was like
ain't gonna be any easier at 67 than 57
ship
so we began this master class by hearing
from dan buettner on his study of
centenarians and i can think of no
better way to end this master class than
by hearing directly from a centenarian
himself his name is mike fremont and he
is 100 years old a 100 year old retired
engineer turned climate activist who
in addition to being pretty darn with it
holds a slew of age group world records
including the fastest recorded marathon
for a 91 year old you heard me right and
at 96 the ripe old age of 96 he set the
american one mile record for his age
group what's perhaps most remarkable
about mike is that his running career
didn't even kick into high gear until
his 60s which for context
was 40 years ago
if you may be feeling like it's too late
that you missed the boat on regaining
fitness i would say take a cue from mike
because you
are incorrect i love chatting with him i
consider him a new friend and i'm proud
to share his story with you this is a
never-before-published clip from my
conversation with centenarian mike
fremont
i guess the first obvious question is
how does it how are you doing like how
do you how do you feel what is it like
to be
a hundred
these believe it or not are the very
best years of my life and
[Music]
no no question why is that
things that i've worked for and worked
on
have
blossomed out
i'm still here
i can still run so to speak
for my age i'm
practically number one
by sheer uh process of elimination but
also i mean it's amazing that you still
get out there you're still running
you're so engaged with life and
um where does the
running begin
running um
i was 36 i had three little children
and my first wife
and she died of a brain hemorrhage
when our daughter was two weeks old
and i was uh i had started a business a
year before
and uh
decided i
was stressed
and i lived on a dam
and i used to run across that dam
which was leveled
right
every day after work
and it was very rewarding it was better
than two martinis
so running was became a little part of
my life
and then they got me in a race
and i did okay
i didn't come in last uh-huh
yeah so it's it's around 60 where you
start getting competitive though
as i understand is that correct
not really
i don't think i ever became competitive
actually until
i was 88. uh-huh
i ran a marathon when i was 88 and i got
first
first
place
in history
in what they call the
single age
running
and then at 90 you do it again the
single age world record for the marathon
and at 90 you also set the single age
world record for the half marathon
and at 91 the single age world record
for the half marathon that's right so
you have
one two four world records
and you have a whole slew of five-year
age group records going it's there's too
many to even keep you i don't even
realize that at the time uh-huh
anyway
there's not much competition out there
there hasn't been
because people don't understand the
system how your system
works and contributes to being able to
do these things so maybe explain how you
do it like how are you how are you able
to
not just run marathons and half
marathons in your late 80s and over the
course of your 90s but also set world
records like what is the secret to
longevity here
the longevity part of it is
the interesting part i think
and the
japanese are credited
uh living
six years longer on average than
americans
that's a huge amount yeah
but here i've already as i'm 22 years
older than the average person who dies
in this country right
and it's been a pleasure
[Music]
and it's simply
simply because of what i eat
and i hold that largely responsible
for all the
records
that i said in old age
no question in my mind absolutely it is
diet that is to determine
my existence my continued existence
and my beautiful health essentially for
the last 30 years you've been eating a
very strict whole
a
100
percent
no exceptions cold turkey so what about
the fitness routine what is the secret
to how you've been able to continue
running into your 90s and now at 100 i
was able to retire at the age of 88.
[Laughter]
so low stress free time
stress also kills
and if you can keep your life from
distress as well as stress
you're very fortunate
my routine had been three times a week
monday
not monday uh sunday
tuesday and thursday
i would run 10 miles until i was 98.
10 miles three times a week
ten miles three times that was
30 miles 10 miles three times a week and
what is it like now uh it's five miles
three times a week
do you do any other kind of exercises
uh up to this year
i've been a canoe racer
on a a lake that's three miles away
so i was one of the first guys out there
with my racing canoe
and another guy in an old canoe came up
to me and says
what kind of canoe is that and i
described it and i said you want to try
it and he said yeah
so we exchanged canoes and he tried it
and he became your canoeing buddy he
became our canoeing buddy
and then we attracted another guy
because we're out there
plugging away
and then i said you know
we had we ought to start a group here
he at the time was 13 years younger than
me
that was 2 000 so i was what uh
78
um yeah he was 13 years younger he was
65.
i said why don't we call it the epa
that's the elderly paddlers association
there you go
so we
attracted a few more we probably got
about
12
all together marilyn
is one of them
who come out on
monday wednesday and friday
that's 7 30 in the morning right and are
you still doing that now yeah you are
well i haven't started the season yet
it's been too cold but the epa lives
lives on oh yeah okay good
has anybody
run a marathon at age 100 i don't think
that that's ever occurred i don't think
so
i really don't think so yeah
i think i could
because i think uh
a marathon
the one i the one i i i
set the world record in
was not overly stressing mm-hmm
it wasn't
no i think i could have gone further
yeah but the fact that you didn't even
kick into your highest gear in running
until you were around 60 and that's when
you kind of really found your
competitive groove with all of this like
it's very inspiring because that's a
period of time where most people would
feel like it's time to slow down and in
in your example that's where i feel like
you really started to get more engaged
with your life
well i'm
very grateful for this opportunity
and that's a major impact i could have
is to reach other people with this
message
because i'm saying it works for me
big time
to be at least
22 years older than the average person
who dies
in america
and i feel
that's not long enough yet
yeah
i sincerely hope that after hearing all
of this vital wisdom your perspective on
aging has shifted from that of
limitation
to a conduit to the healthiest most
fulfilled version of yourself
i trust we offered you a handful of
tools and practices you can implement
today to begin
a renewed journey toward living as well
as you can for as long as you can
if you've been inspired then consider
revisiting or visiting a new my in-depth
conversations with these esteemed guests
the guests you've heard here will have
their episode numbers posted in the show
notes so thanks for listening and
watching and please know that i'm
wishing for all of you
the greatest longevity possible
until next time
peace
plants
[Music]
you